Ngoài Huyên Hóng Nghe Anh, sứng cạnh lâu xuống hồ cũng người đang trời với được hết thưởng sống lại là một việc khi anh ai cũng xuất đậu.
Sư việc xảy ra vào sáng như 1 năm tháng 12, trong khi đăng giọc con hết sáng của gia đình,
Anh Phúc, xin năm 1 gình chỉ trân tảm lắm đạc thành chiương, nghe tiêu hồn và nửa hồ Trung tâm bị chấn.
Nhe lực tức, anh trạc xa ngay hiện chiương và được nhất có một người dây xuống hồ.
Theo hôm chỉ của bọi hơi, sất định được sống nạn ngăn chiều hết anh khúc hiện lâu xuống.
Thôi được đó, nạn nhân lần người đang ông đã tìm tái của sống hiệu hồn thường, anh Phúc hồn người dân thực hiện quy trình xa cố,
sất khoảng 2 đến 3 phút, nạn nhân của sống hiệu hồn tình và được chuyển đến cơ sởi tế để cấp cố.
Được biết, nạn nhân là ông tê, chủ tại sát thành lĩnh, phy et thành chiương, sáng như 1 năm tháng 12, trong quá trình vi truyền trên bờ hồn, ông tê không mai chờ chân xưa xuống nước,
hịt xức khỏi bộm tê đã uống định.
Với hệ gạo giống cảm của mình, anh Phúc được chính quyền định phương thường má chân nạn đồng, anh đã vản với vợ thêm 2 chăm nạn đồng,
có phục vi hạt động của nhóm xe không đồng về tăng chiương để hỗ trận người bệnh với khó khăn.